what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here today
wasn't feeling too well earlier but once
i started feeling better
i was like all right i think i'm ready
to watch this 15 seconds on camera
of jurassic world dominion all day for
this
let's swing into action and see
what it looks like people
oh man we already watched it well we
could do what we used to do
we could go like for dark night you know
when they put the first six minutes in
imax you know you just buy a ticket to
imagine go watch the trailers
refund your ticket and leave the effects
look really great
as expected i'm not gonna lie i did
watch on twitter
uh the leaked footage that they have you
could probably find it i encourage you
to why the hell not
you could find this footage of that was
playing at
some theater i don't think it was in the
u.s it was a pretty
exciting teaser that was showing you
like
the dinosaurs infiltrating the world
and it was pretty damn cool
and i thought like maybe the 15 seconds
might be something along the lines of
that i
really loathe uh the last jurassic world
movie i
enjoy the first one and i load the
second one the crappy held camera
footage that i saw
on twitter made me go oh crap
this looks really cool yeah and i didn't
think they would release it online and
so i was like screw it i'll just watch
it on twitter uh for myself
this that they're releasing that's not
even hinting at just the awesomeness
that i already watched i don't know what
kind of video this is turning into i
don't know if it's like disappointing
this is all fresh to me this is my first
impression of the new jurassic world
movie
i don't love this franchise either the
thing is
every new one i think perhaps maybe even
more than any other franchise
kind of comes with potential promise
just because you know
you're here for the dinosaurs and stuff
like that they can it's like a godzilla
movie they can always remix the humans
the effects
here look terrific and it certainly
looks like jurassic park
things are coming and i like the
redesigned logo with the t-rex go and
the amber
so i just mostly just don't want to hate
the everyone on screen that's that's all
i want
but guys are you looking forward to
jurassic world dominion i really am i
genuinely am really looking forward to
this movie so leave your thoughts down
below
and uh hopefully they release a real
trailer online at some point this week
we'll see